be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so with ant-man having just been
released I thought I might do review for
this film but rather than running things
off the top of my head I figured I'd use
my recent method of creating videos as a
way to give you all my opinion on the
film and where it stands in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as so as a relatively
unknown person to non comic readers
ant-man was actually a bit of a gamble
for Marvel with Edgar Wright's
repertoire of films including Hot Fuzz
Shaun of the Dead and Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world his departure as director
early into ant-man's production left a
lot of people concerned as to whether or
not the film would fall in line with the
high quality of films that we've come to
expect in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the having said that if Edgar Wright's
departure as director resulted in the
film as it was presented to us then I
can't say I'm sad to have seen him go
combining a bit of action and character
development alongside a whole lot of
comedy ant-man shows that even the
smallest characters both metaphorically
and physically can stand on their own
two feet
while Paul Rudd seems to maintain the
same kind of character throughout the
film and that he's introduced to us as a
thief he operates as a thief and
concludes the film as a thief aside from
this desire to prove himself as a hero
in the eyes of his daughter Cassie there
really isn't a whole lot of character
development here having said that Paul
Rudd undertakes the role of Scott Lang
in spectacular fashion if I can be a
little melodramatic here the role of
Scott Lang feels like it was made for
Paul Rudd while this is true from the
perspective of how the film was written
even the source material in terms of
Scott Lang's involvement with the
Avengers in the comics as well as his
current solo series absolutely screams
Paul Rudd the way that Paul read
portrayed Scott Lang seems so natural
here part of this is most likely due to
his talent as an actor and part of it's
probably due to the fact that I can only
assume that there were some improvised
sessions in this film but from the
unease at the responsibility that comes
with being ant-man to his rise as a
superhero
does an incredible job holding up the
film as its main star as one of the more
controversial characters in Marvel
Comics due to the act of striking his
wife Marvel had stated early on that the
character Hank Pym would in no way delve
into this iconic story and instead would
strictly focus on his relationship with
Scott Lang as well as his daughter to
this end Marvel makes up for this by
providing some very deep insight into
the character of Hank Pym himself
without spoiling anything the Hank Pym
as he's portrayed by Michael Douglas as
a man haunted by his actions where Hank
Pym is best known for creating Ultron in
the comic books the regret he
demonstrates in the comics is
transferred to the film but rather than
the source of his regret being Ultron
the source of his regret is his
discovery of the Pym particle and the
inevitable consequences that followed
regarding his wife Janet Van Dyne and
their daughter hope Van Dyne the
furthermore his relationship with Scott
Lang undertakes more of a
teacher-student role than anything else
but this is done in a way that fits the
characters together nicely as opposed to
leaving us feeling as though they were
simply smashed together the teaching
Scott Lang the ropes in terms of how to
use his newfound gifts in a manner that
will help them achieve their combined
goals Michael Douglas does a fantastic
job of leading Scott Lang without
actually becoming overbearing
as a character that does exist in Marvel
Comics her publication history is only
about 14 issues so I think it's safe to
say that Marvel was basically starting
from scratch here especially when you
consider that hope Van Dyne of the
comics was actually a villain that being
said if Hank Hamm was Scott Lang's
instructor and if Scott Lang's daughter
was his reason for becoming ant-man the
hope Van Dyne is the person that helps
Scott Lang overcome his confidence
issues while Hank Pym is more of the
broad brush I guess painting the canvas
of Scott Lang as ant-man hope Van Dyne
fills in the small areas while the
estrangement between herself and Hank
Pym is only explored on the surface the
fact that Evangeline Lilly signed a
multi film contract becomes apparent as
her character left me wanting to see
what kind of development we would
actually see as the character progressed
especially with the events as they
unfolded towards the end of the film
so while the rest of the main cast was
pretty solid I walked away from the film
feeling like Darren cross was the weak
link in the chain now while this is not
meant to be a shot against Corey Stoll
who has proven himself to be a
formidable actor in his own right the
lack of interest regarding dare cross
seemed to be more a writing issue than
anything else while Darren cross is the
first villain the Scott Lang faced after
undertaking the mantle of ant-man the
character in the comics was not the
slightest bit interesting case in point
Darren cross as a villain that only
appears in seven issues of Marvel Comics
dying almost immediately after his
introduction due to a heart condition
and so with Marvel plagued by their
inability to create compelling villains
in solo films it stands to reason that
Darren cross would come up short in
terms of relatability but even more so
than that even a general sense of
interest
now the final topic I'd like to address
here before we get into closing
statements is ant-man's placement in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe again while I
was initially concerned that the film
would fall short and that Marvel would
attempt to compensate by constantly
throwing the Avengers in our faces
the film's ability to stand on its own
two feet mitigates this concern indeed
while it's made clear to us where this
film stands in relation to the timeline
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe as well
as the other films and even the Avengers
themselves this is done both tastefully
and conservatively again without
providing too many spoilers in this
segment what we're told is that this
film basically takes place after
Avengers 2 age of Ultron but directly
before the events of Civil War
so here's a million-dollar question is
the film good absolutely if what you're
looking for is a throwback to how the
Marvel Cinematic Universe got started
with the comedy action combination that
led to the success of Iron Man 1 this
film is absolutely for you because most
of the fight scenes take place with
Scott Lang and his ant-man form the
movie has a totally different feel from
any of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
films so far furthermore I feel like
this takes a great break away from the
darker tone of some of the more recent
films as well as upcoming films like
Captain America 3 and if I can be a
little bold here I'd say this movie
ranks a close second behind guardians of
the galaxy in terms of uniqueness and
contribution to the list of model films
so far without being said I will catch
you guys later please